à l'époque c'était complètement à
quelque chose qui nous a fait qu'on a
fait sans réfléchir quoi y avait aucune
aucune incitation à la haine raciale
c'est l'évidence même je suis
entièrement d'accord sur le fait que
j'ai pu faire du mal et je mange je le
regrette profondément qu à ce moment là
j'ai pu j'ai pu choquer faire de la
peine aujourd'hui je m'en veux
terriblement vue l'amant alors on va
voir le skate dont parle michel leeb
regarde dans l'avion j'avais une petite
faim alors j'ai demandé ma liste de
passagers si le point bas dans le passé
c'est le passé pâle et remarqué ces six
là non moi j'ai dit oui vous rigolez
adam me dit vous vouliez enlevez vos
lunettes de soleil quand vous me parlez
la mêlée alors est ce que michel avait
eu raison de faire son mea culpa
parce que c'est vrai que quand on voit
ce que tu voyais le public ne rigolait
pas du tout c'était un énorme
blockbuster à l'époque c'était vraiment
un sketch est un tube c'est un des tubes
de de michel leeb ou et gilles verdez il
a eu raison mais ça suffit pas je suis
désolé mais vous oui bien sûr mais là il
faut il faut il faut mettre le contexte
dans les allées et n'assure que c'est
inadmissible maintenant mais c'est ce
qu'il a dit oui mais moi ça ne l'était
aussi avancé comme les cris de singes
dans les stages déroutant donc il est
obligé de faire ce mea culpa je trouve
qu'il aurait pu en faire un peu plus
il regrette mais il s'excuse pas assez
pour moi mathieu de l'embout qu'est ce
que tu m'as donges trop kg jo c'est
dommage qui se serait excusée parce que
c'était une époque et chaque époque vit
avec son temps à l'époque justement ce
qui était plus drôle c'est que ce sketch
là ne faisait venu choqué pas et s'ils
ne choquait pas ça veut dire qu'elle est
moins de racisme
ça veut dire qu'il est beau c'est un
dossier à dire qu'il est moins tout ça
aujourd'hui évidemment ça ne me fait pas
rire quand je dors pas du tout ça fait
moins rire encore ses membres comptent
qu'aujourd'hui si on est à ce point sur
les nerfs excusez ma dit que c'est tout
à leur naissance que la blague sur la
burqa je dire à quel point aujourd'hui
tout est une poudrière moi pardon mais
la cage aux folles
les blagues sur les deux mois ça me fait
rire ça me fait rire qu'on fasse des
folles des machins qu'on rit des homos
qu'on rit des noirs qu'on rit de tout le
monde c'est raide manière de s'aimer ça
prouve qu'aujourd'hui on ne s'aime plus
on a un humour qui
uniquement par cast par catégorie et
qu'on ne s'aime plus les uns les autres
et qu'on est tous opposés les uns aux
autres donc non il n'a pas intérêt 3 et
merci il a l'air de dire qu'aujourd'hui
la société mis aujourd'hui qu'avant et
non pardon elle est émue avant alors
peux dire que je voterai un autre sketch
des années 90 et les nuls il avait fait
l'épicier arabe
voilà c'était énorme rappelez vous de ça
et est-ce qu'on peut le faire
aujourd'hui aussi on se pose la question
vient à lui monsieur bonjour monsieur
bah oui oui voudraient une paire de
chaussures en croco c'est pas possible
oui les chaussures voilà voilà où les
virages avec non non je voudrais la
petite pendule plaqué or on a pu aussi
le cadre de marrakech les lumières qui
s'allument à l'électricité au tour c'est
pas facile non plus relax oui oui bien
sûr vous voulez que je l'amène à la
maison c'est possible aussi
oui bien sûr oui et si je te demande en
plus des cacahuètes
oui le costume bleu lac et jolie que je
te paie plus tard tu vas pas me dire que
c'est possible oui oui bien sûr voilà
vers dvi vous allez faire la signature
voilà et ça c'est cadeau ça me fait
plaisir
et comment oui oui la sncf si possible
c'est rire encore ça fait bien fait rire
encore et est exactement aujourd'hui
j'ai le maire oui mais moi je trouve que
me tuer à tout à fait bien résumé mais
il ya plus aucun sketch de le gâteront
temps qui pourrait passer aujourd'hui la
télévision qu'on pense que mes coluche
je faisais un sketch koré moïse et le
viol c'est qu'on veut pas moi jouer
évidemment qui faisait que ce n'est pas
une incitation violent mais c'est un
sketch y passer maintenant ça serait
impossible nous mêmes même autour de la
table je pense que tout le monde
m'attend
il ya plein de sujets ou et franchement
où tourne à l'ong plusieurs formats jpeg
quand on en direct vous dit on va on va
moins loin sur les fesses plusieurs fois
et souvent je me restera et les choses
que j'aurais pu dire est au début
d'émission il ya dix ans je ne dis plus
maintenant ah ouais vous avez peur dix
ans alors je vous parliez coluche
coluche et les fins sketch sur un crs
arabe dans 74 où il parlait des arabes
et des juifs sont égorgés
[Musique]
moi je ne suis pas raciste dire pour moi
je les blancs les français et les noix
[Applaudissements]
un juif l'ontario non j'ai pas des juifs
et arméniens je veux dire à part je lui
dis pas je ne sais rien tous les autres
sont égaux la plus haut
oui je pense que la société devenait
effectivement plus sensibles mais je
pense aussi que les victimes ont pu cela
bhl la parole avant les victimes
n'avaient pas la parole n'y avait pas
les réseaux sociaux on n'écoutait pas
les victimes donc même ceux qui étaient
sensibilisés son santé victime dans une
blague comme ça humoristique n'avait pas
la politique la possibilité de
s'exprimer aujourd'hui ils s'expriment
ils disent ouvertement selon le préfet
qui me choque même a bien fait de
s'excuser vous oui enfin s'excuser le
mot est un peu fort pour reconnaître que
l'époque est différente qu'on
reconnaisse que moi je l'avais dit dans
balances ton post moi j'ai ri des
blagues de michel leeb lui en a qui
m'ont critiqué dammarie à l'époque des
blagues de michel leeb ça m'a fait
récemment ce qui est moins cher
aujourd'hui
ben oui effectivement j'ai l'envié
d'avoir fait ce sketch tout ce qu'on
rigolait l'époque doivent s'excuser
aussi d'avoir pu annoncer une ancienne
époque on a changé d'époque
j'ai eu connaissance mais on la
reconnaît malick sy patte a changé je
suis assez d'accord avec mathieu
d'ailleurs ça me ça me fait mal aux
fesses de dire ça c'est l'époque et on
est tous très tendus
non mais vraiment assez c'est très
compliqué il ya l'arrivée dès réseaux
sociaux on entend à cette année encore
c'est à dire que tout le monde a droit à
la parole d'allah tout le monde donne
son avis tout le monde est journaliste
tout le monde est critique et et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui l'époque est très
tendue on se renferme sur nous mêmes il
ya des le communautarisme a jamais été
aussi présent et c'est c'est dommage
même si c'était pas de rôle à l'époque
c'était une autre époque et je pense
qu'on était un peu plus libre
qu'aujourd'hui et s'excuser je sais pas
si ça change
à quel point je suis fait passer sa
chance quelque chose dans l'histoire
mais c'était pas marrant c'est pas grave
ça arrive
donc voilà aujourd'hui je trouve que
c'est très très compliqué avec les
réseaux surtout alors les guignols
diffusée sur canal+ était habitué aussi
avoir un humour provocateur
on se souvient par exemple en 2001 dans
un sketch il remettait le trophée
d'homme de l'année à oussama ben laden
regarde attendez c'est pas une
récompense à leur appel qu'adolf hitler
a été élu l'homme de l'année en 1938
oui
et si seulement je pouvais faire la même
carrière in celle là c'est dignement
oui je sais c'est pour ça que j'ai été
élu
oui bah si ç'avait truc à moi je leur ai
donné à george w bush pour son action
contre le terrorisme ou ajouts n'y a ni
le maire de new york
tvous avant le 11-septembre était rien
bouchité un crétin est long il passait
son temps à s'engueuler avec son disque
physique ou nas c'est grâce à moi aussi
si des eaux là si quelqu'un ose dire
ouais c'est pas marrant je rigolais pas
à l'époque à ça on a tous rigolé et là
ce serait vraiment hypocrite aujourd'hui
de dire bien sûr à l'époque j'étais un
peu outré non ce pardon je suis d'accord
a rigolé sur les 22 des gens qui nous
ont tous fait rire aujourd'hui si tu
l'airpass parfois tout le monde va faire
le mec un peu chaud mais non et à paille
a pas de quoi être eric alors est ce qui
est compliqué c'est que comme on vit une
époque où on surveille ses paroles ça
nous apparaît comme un âge d'or de la
surface rire ou pas moi je préférais la
période où avant de dire quelque chose
on réfléchissait pas pendant 7 ans parce
que c'est pas de la censure le problème
c'est l'autocensure
maintenant on n'ose pas il ya vraiment
des blagues que qu'on n'ose pas faire
gerald caricature je trouve que michel
leeb a eu tort de s'excuser parce que
oui évidemment c'est plus drôle
aujourd'hui à la lumière de aujourd'hui
mon peut pas on peut pas résumer les
choses à plat avec un regard sur le
passé avec leurs éducateurs ses prix
s'est fait défoncer oui mais moi je me
méfie aujourd'hui de l'humour
en fait avec toujours sous le prisme de
la sensiblerie des curseurs on peut
comprendre pourquoi fellow à remettre le
baromètre de la bonne santé d'une
démocratie dans les dictatures qu'on
interdit de rire de tous nommés juges on
rire de tout les unes de charrier ne me
font pas rire un homme regarde moi je
voudrais m'arrêter moi je pense que là
moi je suis d'accord il fallait quand
même ses yeux la banda los ce ne sont
pas demi lune est ce sont mes narines
c'est normal de faire ça trouve ça drôle
enfin si la nouvelle talât se moque par
exemple de la delà de certaines choses
de la religion musulmane
on va trouver ça drôle la version de son
utilitaire voyez dans un humour
communautaire qui est dévastateur au
sérieux en arabe pour faire des blagues
sur les arabes la loi gayssot et drôle
tu te dis moi je le fais c'est un
scandale c'est le malick ça va être très
bien mais enfin je donnais pas belle
charge tus par exemple en recevant dans
ce spectacle jonah david et fiona tan
que j'ai vu qu'il la rend il fait tout
le spectacle
un gay mais vraiment hague est très fort
ouais ça m'a fait hurler de rire
vraiment les drire mais tant mieux car
tu fasses des homosexuels c'est ce qui
rend c'est ce qui crée l'humour l'amour
et c'est ce qui rend les gens
sympathiques moquez vous dégainez vos
pieds vous les arabes et tous c'est ce
qui fait qu'on va s'aimer
ou alors on attire le plus récent des
z'arts up comedy club jamel était
entouré de fabrice éboué et thomas
n'gijol et aussi c'était boké toutes les
communautés après on va parler des bons
c'est parti tu t'appelles comment tu te
fous de ma gueule tapée le ping pong
[Applaudissements]
changer de prénom pour trouver du
travail en veillant bien simple
orientales jean profité pour dire
quelque chose aux arabes
non ne riez pas c'est votre nom d un
rabbin se compose de pelé cailloux 1 c
et s'il vous plaît pour l'amour de dieu
arrêtez les boulangeries et d'épiceries
c'est mieux vraiment voilà regarder un
petit sondage regarder ce qu'on pense
les gens peut-on encore faire du mois en
2009 oui à 41 % quand même nom à 59 pour
ce rayon